(painfully wailing) "I am sorry!"
So, in the New York Times
In the first sentence of the comment on the falling dog,
Critic Vincent Camby wrote
This is an unusual year,
In the middle of the year,
We found a new, first-rate film director.
Then continue to list four by four
You have not heard of the director’s shooting
Movies you have not seen
They have not lasted for more than ten years
Make a movie before continuing
Now add the name of Quentin Tarantino to the list.
I guess one fifth is not bad.
(screaming)
"You will be fine!"
25 years after that comment, Tarantino
Probably the most popular
a living director who is still working,
May be after Spielberg and Scorsese.
His eight movies are over.
Global $1.5 billion, writing
His work can fill a small library.
This quarter-century milestone is a
Good opportunity to review
The classic level of Tarantino's first film.
I am a little obsessed with the first time,
How things start, and
The first scene of the falling dog
Probably the first thing I think of first.
Ok, yes, obviously
I know this is not technical.
The first movie, but
I have been watching
Before the beginning
Dinner scene as the whole movie of Tarantino
A prelude.
The traditional prelude is the mood setter.
A little bit of music is set up
What is coming soon.
Only in the world of Tarantino,
The prelude is a seven-minute conversation about the merits of Madonna's songs and tips
It is natural.
"But no, people say 'don't spend these people
Give those people a tip,'
That is nonsense. ”
So the first shot of the story
This is appropriate, it is the most exciting
One of the beginnings in the history of film.
Just like the first note in the first one
Led Zeppelin album.
Before you have a chance to wink,
You are involved. Your soul fan
Go forward and back.
In the film, actions are usually taken to produce consequences.
But here, the consequences have actions;
The action you started to imagine.
The robbery had a problem.
[Led Zeppelin's "Good Times Bad Age" is played in the background]
Just like you used to be in the past
You are also in the future,
How long can this guy live?
And what else?
Can do to save him
And of course,
Bleeding like Mr. Orange,
You can't get rid of now,
Because this is pain;
Cruel and specific attention
Until now.
This is pain, the feeling of panic
Time is running out, that
Put this movie with
Other films that start with media resources are separated.
Whenever I create anything,
I always compare it to the beginning of the drowning dog.
My beginning
Can you attract attention like this?
Does it have the same kinetic energy
Let you enter the narrative?
Of course, we are here too.
Jean Tarantino
Famous way
Nonlinear narrative
In the interview, Tarantino made a comparison
Byzantine early film tracks
Novel writing.
"There is always only one novel.
Almost completely free
Tell their stories in the way they see fit,
Ok, that is me.
This is what I want to do. "
But although I think the comparison
The novel is very relevant, I also think there
This is a relationship,
With music.
I think one of them makes
The falling dog became so backward
It is the instinct of Tarantino.
Narrative power.
For me, the order of the movies
Much like a low-key aspect
Pop music; sorting of albums.
One of the reasons I love Abbey Road,
For example, one of the reasons
I have listened to it many times.
Along the way, because
The song sequence took me through.
Even in the first half, that is the first half
There is no mixing and there is a thrust.
I mean, imagine this change.
Feel if the album starts, let's say,
Maxwell's silver hammer.
[Beatle's "Maxwell's silver hammer, playing in the background]
Now imagine the change in feeling
The drowning dog starts here.
"Greeting to a bastard inside.
Cabot is doing a job and doing big things
Fat guy guess who he wants? "
The order of falling dogs
Has the same natural rhythm as the natural rhythm
Album cycle;
Offers a variety of rhythms
From intense, reflective, back,
Link the corresponding scenes together.
All Tarantino films are built this way.
Like an album; prefer an album,
I think, than the novel.
Even those more
Straightforward narrative.
[Rick Ross' "100 Black Coffins", playing in the background]
"When I got an idea,
Part of what I have to do
Is to check that recording room
And check those records,
And go 'find the music'
Or the "personality" of a movie.
It’s like I am looking for rhythm
This movie needs to be played,
I am looking for spirit and rhythm
This movie needs to be played. "
Tarantino is another thing
The most famous is his dialogue.
Of course there are some references
The dog in the water is not so classic.
"Do you know who she is like?
She looks like Christie Love.
Remember the TV show? "
"Get Christie's love, love, love"
"Get Christie's love, love, love!"
"She is the police?" "Oh yeah!"
"You were arrested, sugar!"
(laugh)
No one remembers this show today.
Get Christie’s love,
But what is more important here is the concept;
People are still talking about TV shows,
Entertainment is still a universal language
Between strangers.
"Playing a type role in a type movie
Ok, give them a real life length,
Let them sound like real people
Like, I know, my friend, my friend,
And just other people,
And quote other people's references..."
Falling Water Dog translated into 2017
Because of humanity and comedy
Tarantino Breathing Types
The whole Hollywood still feels.
"It’s all right;
Among them, a great hero
Kevin Bacon
Teach the whole city that is all human
Stick to their ass
Dancing is the best thing. "
I think the only one
The dog is not so classic.
It is Tarantino's own movie.
On all the influences of film culture and popular culture
, it is still very obvious
His most amateur movie.
If the film is released, how will it be recognized?
Is impossible
Because so many cinemas
Received in the past 25 years
The impact of this style.
But I think Siskel and Ebert
Their original comments are very close.
"I like this movie,
I hope it goes a step further and try more. "
"I have the same reaction, that's it.
a lot - a style of practice, 呃
But then I got it very quickly.
I mean, I understand what he wants to do here,
This is what is shown in the crime movie.
The crime movie is not shown.
For example, hey, humor...
But we get "in 15 minutes"
Lost part of the falling dog
Is a more profound character research and exploration
You are in a vulgar novel
Dangerous relationship, shameless bastard and
The liberated Jiang Gezhong got a good idea.
However, I do think
Falling water dog
Tarantino can indeed reach a deeper goal.
Toilet story series.
All the work of Tarantino is commenting
Tell the essence of the story itself,
But Mr. Orange,
Undercover police,
Learn fake stories to sell criminals
His credibility
Is one of the best examples
In all his movies.
He divided the sequence into four parts:
Mr. Orange studied the scene,
Mr. Orange rehearsed the scene,
Orange shows the story to the audience.
Finally, the story "lives" over.
This is an elegant illustration, how to speak
Can become a story,
And the story becomes a reality,
Or enter the movie.
This is a good touch, the only thing
This makes the police not notice the drugs
Is a similar storyline,
Because the story also makes us unable to see the reality.
"Badi, I want to shoot your face with a gun.
If you don't put your hand on the fucking flush button! "
As a genre and style exercise,
The falling dog is great.
One of the best in the movie, and
If it lags behind
The remarkable height that Tarantino later had to achieve,
That is not criticism, because,
I mean, let's see you reach your goal.
“Just lacking transcendence”
Your first movie.
I think this is a good rule of thumb.
How classic is the movie?
Simply put, do we keep
Look at them.
25 years have passed, I am still watching the dog,
I bet it is still true
More than 25 years from now.
Hey everyone,
Thank you very much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by VRV.
VRV is a combined service
Lots of great content channels
Like Rooster Teeth, Mondo,
After testing, cartoon hangover,
Crunchyroll and Funimation, having them cool
Two in the same place,
You can download the VRV app
Xbox, Playstation, iOS or Android,
If you get a VRV package
At this link you can get a 7 day
Free trial.
Once you get that combination pack,
I suggest you take a look
The show is called March like a lion.
At Crunchyroll, this is a revelation
A 17-year-old Shogi player
(Shogi is a Japanese foreign variant of chess)
Really nice, very beautiful, very melancholic,
I think you will like it very much.
Adam Savage’s day is built on top of the test
It’s a great time.
All shows are HD and no ads.
I definitely recommend that you check out the VRV app.
I will see you next time.